In today's video,
we're going to be playing
with sulfur hexafluoride,
and see if it can be used to put out
1,000 burning candles at once.
[Music]
Hey guys, I'm Nate.
And I'm Calli.
This stuff is weird.
Oh no.
This is as high as I can make
my voice go right now.
In his video, Nick Uhas
tried to put out
three hundred candles
with sulfur hexafluoride.
We're going to try a thousand.
Sulfur hexafluoride is
a really dense gas
that doesn't burn,
and so, you can use it
to actually extinguished things
that are burning.
We currently have this tub
full of sulfur hexafluoride.
As demonstrated by this balloon,
which is just full
of normal breath air,
which is now floating
on the sulfur hexafluoride.
Sulfur hexafluoride is
between five and six
times more dense than air,
so balloons will float on it,
and it should stay in this box.
We're going to play around
with it for a little bit,
and then we're going to see
if we can take what Nick did,
and scale it up a lot,
and put out a thousand
tea light candles at once.
Here's the basic idea.
Sulfur hexafluoride is a heavy
gas that displaces oxygen,
and doesn't burn.
So we think if we
fill this container,
we might be able to pour it out,
and put out 1,000 burning
candles all at once.
Now, this stuff is most famously
known as deep breath gas,
because when you breathe it in,
because it's so
much heavier than air,
it does make the sound coming
from your vocal chords
sound much deeper.
I've no idea what
you're talking about.
It can be
a pretty drastic change.
This isn't a helium balloon.
In normal air,
it just falls to the ground
or the table like normal.
Gets you a
little bit lightheaded,
kind of like helium.
It displaces air,
including air in your lungs.
It's so much heavier
than normal air,
it won't push it out.
So you really have to breathe
in and out a lot to get
it out of your body.
Otherwise, you're just going
to start getting lightheaded.
So yeah, balloon just falls
to the desk normally,
other than the fact that it's
like got static electricity,
and sticking to my hand
a little bit.
But once you really
let go of it, it falls.
But you let go of it
in the sulfur hexafluoride,
it's floating on the gas there.
This little foil scoop here,
and currently, it's
just full of normal air.
Doesn't do anything to a candle.
But carefully scoop
up some completely
invisible sulfur hexafluoride...
Puts it out immediately.
[Music]
That took nothing.
That worked great.
Oh, this is gonna be amazing.
[Music]
I mean, we do have
several flamethrowers,
which hopefully will make it
so it doesn't take so
long to light them all,
when we're ready to do
the actual burn.
I've got my hair down,
so I'll let Nate
handle the lighting.
And now, worry about organizing.
[Music]
Guys, we've now got
one thousand candles
on the workbench.
I actually didn't think
it was going to fit,
but they did.
>> We've got--
>> Should add more.
We've got 28 candles
going this direction,
and we've got 35 going here.
That's the complete rows,
and then in our 36th row,
we've got another 20.
So we've got 980 in the grid,
plus 20 more,
it's a thousand total candles.
So before we light them,
what we're going to do
is add a barrier.
We're going to take
some foam core,
and just tape it to the sides
of the workbench so it goes up
above the level of the candles,
and that way,
any sulfur hexafluoride
pouring down won't just
like run off the table.
It should stay contained,
make sure everything gets put
out the way it should.
Guys, today is the last day
to get these two t-shirts
in our store for only $19.99.
Get yours now.
Click the link
in the description below.
[Music]
I think it's time to start
lighting some candles.
It's gonna take a while.
We can do it.
[Music]
You just stay on the--
Ah, there's so many going out.
It's okay.
I'm light--
I'm gonna keep lighting.
You start pouring.
Try the blow torch.
Oh my gosh.
It's like a furnace
putting my arm over it.
Just trying to light
the ones in the middle.
There's, there's like more out
than lit now.
Go, go, go!
You're blowing these out.
You're actually just
blowing them out.
We don't have a back-up plan.
This was the backup plan.
Let's just pour it on.
3, 2, 1.
[Music]
All right, a couple things
have gone wrong here.
Oh my gosh, I can't breathe.
Well, it didn't go
the way we planned,
but there's more few more things
that we can try
that should make it pretty cool.
There was a lot of heat coming
off of those candles.
Enough that the candles
in the middle just
completely liquefied,
and when that happened, a lot of
the wicks started to curl over,
and they actually
got submerged in the wax,
and stop burning.
Doesn't matter how many times
you try and pull those out,
there's enough heat
radiating off of this
that we could fix
it all fast enough.
And combine the wicks
being partially submerged,
even like that,
they may be able to burn.
Like this one here
is fairly exposed.
So I might be able to light
that wick right now,
and maybe it will stay burning,
but we had so much
like of a draft
from that many candles
that there wasn't,
you know, all of the air
was just getting disturbed,
and so nothing
was staying still,
and so we just had so many
that wouldn't stay lit.
So we did for the sulfur
hexafluoride on probably 600
of them still burning?
But we want a thousand.
So as I said,
the problem is
that the wicks were getting
submerged in the liquid wax.
So what we're doing now
is just going to cut
some little strips
of paper towel,
and dip those into the candles,
and have them sticking
out over the edge
so they can't be submerged,
and then we'll
try lighting that,
and paper towels should work
to wick the wax up pretty well,
and hopefully, keep
everything burning.
[Music]
Okay, we-- We lit
the table on fire.
So now, this is a matter
of we really need this to work.
3, 2, 1.
[Music]
It's really close!
And now, go outside.
Outside!
It worked,
except I'm worried
about my co-workers.
Come on.
We got most of the candles lit,
and the ones that went out,
we actually took pieces
of paper towel
like Nate was saying.
We dipped them
into the melted wax,
and we are able to relight them.
So for any gaps
that you might have seen,
we had two or three weeks going
in other candles
to make sure we
still had a thousand lit,
and then the table lit on fire.
So it actually worked out,
and now, we're just
airing out the room.
We'll be able to see
the results in a minute.
It's very smoky.
[Music]
This is actually amazing.
But you can actually see areas
where we had a lot
of overheating problems,
and we set the table on fire.
Yeah.
Yeah, there was a lot of heat.
Yeah, the--
We did--
I would say you
just avoid doing that.
Yeah, maybe stick
of the 300 tea lights.
Three hundred and space
them out quite a bit more.
It was really fun.
We actually managed
to get it to work.
Most of the sulfur hexafluoride
did blow out most
of the candles,
which was really cool.
But then the smoke
alarms went off.
Yeah.
Thanks for the idea, Nick.
Guys, today is
the last day of our sale.
You can get both
of these shirts for $19.99 each.
Get your own by clicking that
link in the description below.